Well, our trip was over.
And I'm happy the say that not even
Jordan could ruin Italy for me.
We had an unforgettable time.
And our journey's already being lauded
as a triumph of classic Italian cinema.
Ladies and gentlemen,
here is the movie trailer.
(laughing)
(applauding)
Hello.
Alright, Ciao.
Where is everyone from in the class?
(speaking in a foreign language)
She's asking if I'm your assistant?
No, he does nothing.
What are you saying?
I have various tasks.
No, he doesn't have various tasks.
He does not have the vocabulary of the
Italian language, but
he has the drama of the
Italian language.
I have the drama,
I use my hands.
How do you say hands?
(grumbling)
She has the authority in this room.
She is the teacher.
She is in control.
They are well behaved, they listen.
And look at you.
You're an animal.
You eat a brochure.
She said I'm an animal?
Did she say I'm an animal?
I am paraphrasing.
Okay, I should probably explain.
Two students left, they
couldn't take it anymore.
Ray, can you say why you
think those two left?
(laughing)
(spy music)
(motorbike puttering)